au lendemain d'une fête à paris une
jeune femme se réveille dans sa
baignoire avec des glaçons et une
cicatrice dans le dos avec un petit
pansement
elle va à l'hôpital et à l'hôpital on
lui apprend qu'on lui a volé un rat
cette histoire elle la tournée beaucoup
elle tourne encore beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux elle est née sur
instagram au mois d'octobre dernier on
la retrouvait sur twitter sur facebook
sur snapshot avec une alerte attention
jeunes femmes peut-être jeune homme fait
attention dans les soirées dans lesquels
vous allez on risque de vous endormir
pour voler un organe en l'occurrence 1
voire 2 1
alors j'ai essayé de remonter à
l'origine de cette rumeur c'est pas
facile parce que les rumeurs elle naît
souvent de choses un peu difficiles à
retrouver parce que c'est un petit bruit
c'est des choses qu'on entend qu'on
répète mais il ya des chercheurs des
historiens qui sont montés à l'origine
qui pensent que l'origine de cette
rumeur
elle remonte à la fin des années 80
notamment une année en 1987 on voit
remonter pas en europe pas aux états
unis mais en amérique centrale et en
amérique latine cette histoire sous une
forme un peu différente qui prend celle
souvent des bébés en pièces détachées
l'histoire c'est dans des orphelinats
des grandes familles riches d'américains
du nord notamment des états unis vont
allez adopter des enfants
au paraguay au brésil en argentine ou en
amérique centrale dans des pays plutôt
pauvre pas pour les adopter en vrai mais
pour lorsqu'il arrive aux états unis
leur prendre des organes les tuer
en prenant des yeux prenant le coeur les
poumons prenant les prenant les reins
une histoire sordide terrible et qui va
prendre avoir un écho très important à
la fin des années 80 notamment parce que
ça nourrit l'idée qu'il y a aux etats
unis un rapport de force qui est
profondément asymétrique que les états
unis par leur puissance militaire leur
puissance économique peuvent imposer
leur diktat sur le sud et faire ce
qu'ils veulent y compris des corps des
gens du sud
ce qui est intéressant c'est de
comprendre aussi pourquoi dans ces
années là cette rumeur elle commença
beaucoup et pas avant et après ne s'est
jamais arrêté en fait c'est parce que
dans ces années la fin des années 80 on
commence à voir de plus en plus
d'articles sur ce qu'on appelle le
trafic d'organes et ça c'est pas une
rumeur
il y avait effectivement des gens des
pauvres notamment en inde qui vendent
leurs reins par exemple on a des riches
émirati des gens du golfe qui font ce
qu'on appelle du tourisme de
transplantation on a aussi des chinois
qui viennent riches chinois qui vont en
inde à bombay notamment ou qui vont dans
les philippines dans l'asie du sud-est
pour aller dans des cliniques où ils
peuvent aller se faire transplanter des
rincon à n'ont pas volé mais acheter à
des familles pauvres ce qui est très
différent ça va pas dire que c'est moins
choquant c'est même terrible d'en venir
à une tel niveau de pauvreté qu'on a
besoin de vendre son corps des parties
de son corps mais c'est sûrement là à la
fin des années 80 que ce thème commence
à prendre et par la rumeur le trafic
d'organes donc la vente de ses organes
devient finalement le vol d'organes et
va arriver progressivement chez nous et
le point de contact entre les deux
histoires
c'est l'histoire d'un turc se turkcell à
m cos et il en 1989
l'histoire défraye la chronique
notamment au royaume uni
il est à londres et il se réveille d'une
opération dans un hôpital à londres il
regarde autour de lui et en fait on lui
a volé un rein
ça c'est ce qu'il va raconter aux médias
il va dire je suis venu avec des
passeurs turquie m'ont dit il ya du
boulot en angleterre à londres et je me
suis retrouvé dans une clinique mon lit
à côté de mon lit
il y avait le lit d'un riche ami un
riche anglais à qui on a transplanté
mongrain volé cette histoire elle a
vraiment fait beaucoup parler d'elle au
royaume uni et même en france cet
article qui en parlent aux états unis un
peu partout
c'est une histoire totalement bidon ce
type là en effet s'est réveillé dans la
dans la clinique avec son rat en moins
sauf qu'en fait il avait vendu son rein
et parce qu'il n'était pas content du
prix qu'on lui avait donné il avait
inventé cette histoire
mais à l'époque personne ne parle de
l'invention il n'ya que sa version à lui
celle d'un vent
organe qui est répéter répéter répéter
voyez on est à la fin des années 80 il
ya une série d'indicateurs une série de
faits bien réels qui vont faire que
cette rumeur
elle va prendre corps c'est une histoire
qui a donc largement précédé l'existence
des réseaux sociaux bien avant même
l'exemple l'existence d'internet est
vrai que on voit régulièrement renaître
ce genre de rumeur à travers internet je
vais quelqu'un balance une vieille
rumeur et avec la puissance des réseaux
de cette petite musique de attention à
vous parce qu'il peut y avoir
dehors dans la rue des gens qui ont
intérêt à voler à voler vos organes pour
les revendre pour en faire du business
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
fort très enracinée ça fait des
décennies que ça dure et c'est pas près
de s'arrêter